reject Nation we are here
it's it's early it's early rejects
I was like oh I'm doing I'm not doing it
anymore we got ourselves an official
trailer for Transformers rise of the
beasts I am so excited for this movie
now we got ourselves an official trailer
more than terracons more than the
Autobots you know what I'm really
excited for
Anthony Ramos yes my man I'm so excited
for Anthony Ramos as a man who looks
Latino but isn't actually Latino I
couldn't be more excited for the
representation that we're getting in
this movie let's go into this trailer
before we do it leave a like do it do it
for America for America and Anthony
Ramos
[Music]
centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden on
Earth
yes yes Darkness has found us again
a better shot of air razor there
about the fate of all living things
[Music]
they officially confirm you across
country
[Music]
Ramos and Mirage Becca Oh I thought we
were boys
you want it
I brought a human here I'm nobody I
ain't even seen nothing I'm not even
seeing anything right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
uh he eats planets so like way bigger
than a planet
boy
it doesn't even matter everything you
cared for
maybe there's another way to save our
home the Mayan calendar you've never
faced anything like this
let them come
[Music]
on
awesome we got ourselves a water
let's go
I'm sure they're over
Take the Wheel
is he controlling I mean it looked like
he was about to be enveloped in in
Autobot nano technology put some Iron
Man stuff right there he's about to have
his own suit is that his voice going
yeah baby so he was actually like
controlling the Transformer I guess so I
mean that's that's what I get the the
the sense from Take the Wheel like I
don't feel like it would just you know
coat him in something he has no
controllers yeah oh awesome yeah I mean
Unicron has been I believe since the I
barely remember those other movies
honestly I Erica's favorite franchise I
did a reaction to the last two Michael
Bay movies it would be like I'm watching
them for the first time ever the way
they should be seen But if I'm not
mistaken one of I believe it was the
last night where they they did tease
Unicron already and then the big theory
has been that Unicron is gonna be the
ultimate big Baddie that we are building
to the fact that the trailer did yeah
confirm it's not only in name but
visuals as well I think is going to be
very exciting for Transformers fans all
across the board to have the big Baddie
coming this way but right now let's just
focus on the immediate plot hackers you
know they're going to win in this movie
they're gonna win at the end of the day
but we will build there because I feel
like this movie is going to be the one
that many of us believe is going to
reset the timeline because while this is
a sequel to the prequel but it's still a
prequel to The Original films this one's
definitely gonna do something with the
timeline considering they have all of
our beasts in action here every one of
them looks really great you know like as
much as we love our Bumblebee as much as
we love love or Optimus Prime you know
like we're getting all these great shots
of Primal in here we're getting all
these great shots of like Chi tour we're
getting these great shots a mirage I
just want to hear Pete Davidson talk he
gets a lot of crap but you know what I
think Pete Davidson is actually funny so
you know what he's just one of those
people people where people just talk bad
about them all the time yet he is so
successful and gets all the ladies for a
reason because he's really funny because
he's with your girl right now I know for
some reason people were like oh pretty
but you know what Pete Davidson he's
gonna be funny in here because he's
essentially serving the role that you
would give to bumblebee to bumblebee
could talk yeah
radio and clip-its if he had a popular
comedian's Personality yeah everyone
looks great here you know uh what but
John and I and I feel like you know if
he if Anthony Ramos's Noah is able to
get the powers uh or able to use like
some type of nanotech to be able to
Pilot himself a Transformer that would
really make it seem like okay movie is
not just some human I mean angel in the
fight yeah and I think the character is
supposed to be you know like a military
technology X expert rather than every
man you know uh we did our research on
Anthony Ramos no right Noah he's gonna
be the new leader of the friend forget
Optimus Prime forget Unicron even
Megatron is all about Noah moving
forward but hey I've been up all here
for a human who feels vital to this
stuff I mean no shade to Sam Witwicky
but but yeah I don't know that could be
a pretty cool development and it's nice
to have a big huge you know a notable
villain who isn't going to be Megatron
yeah it's nice to break from that and
yeah also to have a situation where it
feels like maybe it kind of makes some
sense that they're fighting on Earth and
the Earth is related to this in some way
with the Predacons uh you know going
after the maximals and whatnot the
maximals hiding on earth like I don't
know I feel like that could even you
know the earthliness of the stakes
before we go to the cybertroness of the
stakes you know in the beginning of this
show they're saying it's not our fight
you know that that usual like this is in
our fight we don't need to get involved
but if they are following the Beast Wars
storyline at all it's their fight yeah
it's important yeah for sure
well and you know Optimus primal being
like a direct descendant of Optimus
Prime too like both ties in Earth's
involvement but also the greater scoping
involvement of you know Autobots and
Transformers of all benevolent varieties
well the uh final battle at the end
where they're fighting all the terracons
because you know if like terracons are
just essentially zombie-like
Transformers and and then you have like
all these great shots of all the
Transformers working together what I do
love is the visual that it's just like
Transformers they're like it's Autobots
maximals and terracons fighting each
other at the very end and it's such a
glorious looking shot and RC really
getting a chance to shine here uh in in
the battle sequences as well because
while like it does have like a dark
looking cinematography especially to
have the bleakness kind of reminds me
like the infinity War battle with
whatever those creatures are called you
know uh there's still a a good color pop
with it with enough of our protagonist
characters here at the very end that I
think looks great yeah
um they have that dingy grimy dirtiness
but then that gives you a good
opportunity to be able to well identify
who are here yeah I hope all the all the
maximals get an opportunity for their
personalities to shine you got Scourge
in in the voice of Peter Dinklage so I
hope they actually utilize
scores in order for him to you know
really just stand out Beyond like hey
you're another version of Megatron you
know I mean they have like these shots
in the trailer where he's like whooping
bumblebees ass but I'm wondering if
bumblebee gets taken out of battle and
then it's part of the Nano it looks like
the nanotech forms to Noah no via Ramos
yeah right yeah well uh yeah I mean
that's certainly the sense I got is
there's got to be it's it either way
it's nanotech equipped but also yeah
something that can create a bond a link
Etc and and maybe there's a transformer
in the mix uh who can you know mimic the
shape of other Transformers so maybe
that's not an actual bumblebee getting
murked uh is that Raj the one was able
to do that is that Mirage there you go
that would make a lot of sense create
Illusions and things like that create
likenesses so maybe that's a sacrifice
yeah too alrighty guys well thank you so
much for being here what did you think
of this transfer performers rise of the
Beast trailer are you excited for this
film I hope you are hey leave a like
subscribe I'm gonna get this video to
y'all right now it's already been to you
but in my time of filming this
I'm working on it